j'ai été indigné par les présidents par
les propos du président de la république
j'ai été indigné par ces propos parce
qu'il n'a pas dit que cela il a dit
aussi que les non vaccinés n'étaient pas
des citoyens or ce n'est pas au
président de la république de trier
entre les bons et les mauvais français
il faut les accepter tels qu'ils sont il
faut les diriger les rassembler sans les
insulter alors oui faut avoir le courage
de dire la vérité mais l'insultent n'est
jamais la bonne solution alors oui il
faudra mettre fin à ce quinquennat du
mépris je veux y mettre fin je suis
d'ailleurs la seule à pouvoir en
terminer avec un président qui
visiblement ne supporte plus les
français quand ils ne pensent pas comme
lui nous avons besoin aujourd'hui non
pas de fracture et la france n'ont pas
de diviser les français n'ont pas de
trier entre ceux qui ne sont rien ceux
qui sont quelque chose ceux qui sont
réfractaires et ceux qui sont
disciplinés on doit aujourd'hui conduire
ce pays le réparer et l'on doit
certainement j'allais dire
imaginez un autre quinquennat le
gouvernement est complètement dans le
zig zag on voit bien finalement tout ça
c'est une stratégie d'un président
candidat qui veut mettre un écran de
fumée devant le débat démocratique parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en train
d'aller faire l'audit de son bilan et
caisses de kwassa père soit on sait que
la france après cinq ans d manueel
macron elle est abîmée
l'école est abîmée l'hôpital est à bout
de souffle pourquoi ne parle t'on pas
dans l'hémicycle de serre et animations
dans lesquels nous n'avons plus de
personnel elle est où la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron pour la santé des
français et puis il ya la république il
ya la sécurité vous savez que demain
j'irai à cavaillon une ville ou encore
hier il y a eu des exactions qui ont été
commises par des dealers qui sont en
train jaillir de prendre en otage un
certain nombre d'habitants des quartiers
de la ville donc oui il y a un bilan d'
emmanuel macron il ya un temps de la
présidentielle et ce temps là emmanuel
macron ne doit pas nous l'occulté avec
des écrans de fumée et les insultes aux
français cette déclaration d'hier
fracassante n'est là que pour occulter
le débat démocratique
la république là mal la france est
endettée comme jamais les déficits sont
abyssaux et aujourd'hui les français
sont en insécurité c'est ça le bilan des
manuels macron et que la crise que vit
ne viennent pas le culte et qu'il ya une
insécurité culturel aujourd'hui des
français qui se disent est ce que demain
la france que nous aimons sera toujours
la france ou est ce qu'elle sera
fracturé en communauté et moi ce qui
m'inquiète avec le président de la
république sait que c'est un président
qui divise et qui fracturent moi ce que
je souhaite aujourd'hui c'est réaffirmer
cette fierté française c'est que quel
que soit les racines des français d'où
qu'ils viennent je veux construire un
arbre un tronc un tronc commun